Okay, so that was building permits, a
really useful leading indicator in the
United States,
obviously for traders predicting stock
market direction, GDP growth direction,
and our portfolio
bias. So as a number, you will have seen
it has far reaching implications for the
wider US economy,
because it tells us so many things that
are going on in the US economy at any one
moment in time,
all embedded in one number. So again, like
other indicators, guys, go through the
data and get it
every month, go through it, be on top of
it, understand it, and interpret it
correctly. Okay,
you'll not only get a very good idea of
what's going on in the US economy,
but you'll also get a really good insight,
a really good take for your portfolio
bias.
And you'll also potentially get a lot of
trade ideas from it too. So now we're
going to continue
building out our macroeconomic dashboard.
And we're going to be looking at small
business in the US.
So the business surveys that we've looked
at so far, we've really been focusing on
big business
and corporations in the US. Okay. If we
want to get a full picture of what's going
on in the economy,
we can't only focus on big business and
corporations. We also have to bring in to
our analysis,
the small business sector, because it's
very large, and it's very important to the
US economy.
So what we're going to be doing is looking
at a data set called the NFIB Small
Business Optimism Index.
And with this data, which comes out on a
monthly basis, we get an insight into the
health of a large
part of the US economy, that being the
small business sector. Also, we can create
our own
indices from this data. So we can take the
sub components of the data set, and we can
create
our own indices to get a clearer picture
of what's going on in the US economy. So
we're going to
introduce you now to the ITPM NFIB SBO
leading index. Now, of course, that's a
mouthful, but don't
worry, it's all going to become clear. So
again, we have a download for this video,
go to the downloads
area, and you'll see that navigate to the
downloads area, and you'll see all the
data sets and see how
everything fits together. You will be
using this again as a template on a
monthly basis in conjunction
with all of the other data sets that you
update on a monthly basis for your leading
indicator suite,
your macroeconomic dashboard. So after
this video, we're going to jump straight
in actually to the
next video, which will be cyclical
commodity prices in video number 12. So
let's get into this video,
and I'll see you back at the desk at the
end of video number 12.
Okay, so welcome to video number 11. We're
going to be looking at now small
businesses in the United
States. So we're going to be looking at
our seventh leading indicator, the NFIB
Small Business Optimism
Index. So how does this fit in to our list
of leading indicators that we've covered
so far?
Well, we have our money market leading
indicators in the government bond and
corporate bond markets,
and we have our money supply accessory. We
also have our stock market volatility, our
multiple surveys,
and the NFIB Small Business Optimism Index
is one of those surveys. So we're adding
the NFIB Small
Business Optimism Index to our surveys
list. So what is it? What is the NFIB
Small Business Optimism Index? Well,
the NFIB is the National Federation of
Independent Business. It's the largest
small business trade
association in the United States. And
there's a monthly assessment that's
reported by the NFIB. It's called the
Small Business Economic Trends Report. And
it's a monthly assessment of US small
business activity. So the US
small business economy and its near term
prospects, the data is collected through
mail surveys from random
samples of the NFIB membership. And the
data is reported on the second Tuesday of
each month for the previous month.
So the Small Business Optimism Index is a
composite of 10 small business economic
trends. So SBET indicators that provide
monthly summary data for the state of the
small business economy in the US. Now, the
Small Business Optimism Index is
actually classed by economists as a
coincident indicator. So the aggregate
index, the Small Business Optimism Index,
is classed by economists as a coincident
indicator because it tells us on average
what is going on
right now in the small business part of
the US economy. However, as traders and
portfolio managers,
what are we interested in? What are we
interested in? Well, we are interested in
indicators that lead the economy. We're
not
really that interested in coincident or
lagging indicators. There's 10 sub
components of the Small Business Optimism
Index.
And there's leading indicators within
these 10 SBET indicators that traders and
PMs focus on. So we're going to be looking
at the
aggregate index, but also the important
leading indicators that are components of
the overall index.
Now, why in the world would we care or
even want to look at small businesses in
the US? Why is small
business important to us? Well, small
businesses in the US account for roughly
50% of gross domestic product in the US.
And in terms of employees, 50% of all US
private sector employees work for small
businesses.
And that's defined as having 500 employees
or less. So 500 employees or less, we can
look at the workforce
that makes up that 50% and the composition
of the size of these businesses by
employees hired.
So, for example, businesses that have 100
to 499 employees, this is 15% of the
workforce.
In the US, 20 to 99 employees, that's 17%
of the workforce. 5 to 19 employees,
that's 13% of the workforce.
So this makes up, in total, 50% of
employees in the private sector.
And if we look at registered businesses in
the United States, there's 29 million
registered
firms in the US. And over 99% of those
registered companies are classed as small
businesses.
So having fewer than 500 employees. And
when we look at it and break it down, the
vast majority,
so 88% of the 29 million registered firms
have fewer than 20 employees. Now, when we
look at it as a,
from a revenue perspective, in terms of
the size of these businesses by revenue,
in terms of revenue, amongst small
business, the following approximate
distribution applies as of 2020.
So companies that have under $100,000 in
revenue, that's the majority, that's 40%
of small businesses.
Companies that have $100,000 to $500,000
in revenue, that's 30%.
So we have 70% of businesses making under
$500,000 in revenue.
$500,000 to $5 million in revenue, that's
around a quarter of businesses.
And then $5 million to $50 million
revenue, that's around 5%. So that's in
the minority.
So taken together, you can see why it's
very important when we're trying to get a
handle,
as traders and portfolio managers, on the
future expectation of direction of GDP
growth,
the level of GDP growth, and potentially
direction of the stock market and the
return of the stock market.
It's very important for us as traders and
PMs that we don't ignore small business in
the United States.
In fact, we shouldn't be ignoring it. We
should be embracing it and trying to
figure out what is
happening in the small business sector in
the US. Of course we should. Why? Because
it's very important.
If we just look at it on a GDP level, it's
50% of US GDP is accounted for by small
business.
50% from an employee perspective, 50% of
all private sector employees are from
small business.
And in terms of revenue, if we think about
it from the level of revenue perspective
and the types of
businesses that are driving this
contribution to US GDP, so the 50%
contribution to US GDP,
and the 50% contribution to private sector
employees. If we think about it from a
revenue perspective,
what types of businesses are driving that
contribution? Well, 70% of small
businesses
businesses are making less than 500k
revenue in a year. And from the 5 million
level, if we include that,
it's 95% of small businesses are making
less than 5 million revenue per year. So
it's these businesses that
are making the significant contribution to
the 50% of US GDP and the 50% of US
private sector employment. So it's pretty
pretty obvious that as traders and
portfolio managers, we need to be
concentrating a lot on what is going on in
the small business sector in the US.
So let's think about this in terms of the
US. If 50% of all private sector employees
in the US are working for companies that
have 500 employees or less, then 50% are
working for big business in the private
sector.
So if small business accounts for 50% of
GDP share, then big business and
government and public spending accounts
for 50%.
So it therefore stands to reason that
small business is just as important, if
not more important than big business in
determining US GDP growth and S&P 500
direction.
And of course, the private sector way more
important than government.
Now, similar to survey indicators that
we've looked at so far in the PTM video
series,
there's optimistic conditions, and there's
pessimistic conditions, okay, and we get
responses in surveys that are leading
towards optimism and pessimism.
And it's no different in the small
business sector. We look at it in the same
way.
So as small businesses grow more
optimistic about the future, they are
getting more bullish about the future, and
vice versa, if they
become more pessimistic, they're becoming
more bearish on the future. So when they
get more optimistic, they plan to hire
more people, invest more money in the
business to grow it, increase inventories,
and potentially plan to raise prices for
goods and services.
When they get more pessimistic, they plan
to lay off more people, they plan to cut
back on business investment, and take
risks, and decrease inventories or hold
lower levels of inventories in order to
stay nimble and cautious, and they tend to
hold prices steady, or plan to cut prices
to maintain revenue levels.
So now, if you think back to previous
leading indicators that we've looked at,
when we looked at components of those
leading indicators, so if you think back
to the ISM Manufacturing Report on
Business, and the ISM Services Report on
Business, so the Non Manufacturing Report
on Business, if you recall, we looked at
components within the aggregate index.
So the components that make up the
aggregate index, so the components that
make up the aggregate indices, and if you
remember, in ISM Manufacturing, and if you
remember, in ISM Manufacturing, we looked
at new orders as being the most important.
In the ISM Services or non-manufacturing,
we looked at business activity and new
orders as the most important components
and leading indicators within the
composite index, and the leading
components of the NFIB can be used in
exactly the same way, and can be used in
conjunction with these leading indicators
to get a better understanding of the value
of the NFIB.
So that's why we've got to get a better
understanding of the future economy.
Now, if you go to the downloads area
underneath the video, you'll see three
spreadsheet files in the downloads area
that have been taken from the URL that's
on the screen now, NFIB-SBET, so
NFIB-SBET.org.
You can get all the data sets from that
website, but we have organized the data
sets into a much easier digestible format,
and you can download these three
spreadsheet files and start looking at the
data and looking at the visuals, the
charts, and begin to really understand how
the NFIB Small Business Optimism Index
works.
And it's split into three parts and it's
split into three parts.
We have components, we have regions in the
United States, and we have it split up by
industry.
And of course, every month, you can get
the data yourself when the data is
released, and you can update your
spreadsheets to keep them updated in your
folders.
Now, later in the video, we are going to
be going through the most important areas
of the NFIB Small Business Optimism Index,
so we'll be covering that for you.
But let's have a look first at the NFIB
Small Business Optimism Index survey
design.
How is it actually designed?
So, each month, the NFIB sends out what is
called the Small Business Economic Trends
Survey, the SBET survey.
And there's 10 equally weighted,
seasonally adjusted variables, which are
essentially questions, and then the
responses are taken to make up the Small
Business Optimism Composite Index, which
is the Coincident Index, or considered to
be Coincident, because it's telling us
overall what's going on right now in the
economy, not necessarily leading at the
composite level.
So, these 10 questions make up the 10
components, and the responses contribute
proportionately 10% each to the overall
monthly change in the index.
So, let's have a look at these areas that
small businesses are surveyed on each
month.
Let's have a look at these.
Firstly, do you have any plans to increase
employment?
Is now a good time to expand?
What are your plans to increase
inventories?
Do you expect the economy to improve?
Are you expecting real sales to go higher?
What is current inventory?
Is that up or down versus the last month?
What are current job openings, up or down
versus last month?
What are your expected conditions for the
future of the credit market?
Do you have any plans to make capital
outlays?
And what are you seeing in earnings
trends, up or down versus last month?
Now, when you look at these questions, I'm
going to leave it to you to decide for a
short period of time.
We will cover it a little bit later in the
video.
But I'll leave it to you to decide for the
moment what you think would be a leading
indicator and what you think would be a
coincident indicator.
So, stew on that for a while.
Have a think about it.
Let's put it this way.
There's some clues in the words that are
used in the questions.
But let's have a look at the NFIB Small
Business Optimism Index, where it is
actually located.
In terms of the survey design, what you'll
actually see each month when it comes out.
So, the data goes back to January 1986.
And what we've got on the screen here is
the January 2021 report.
And you can see the chart of all data.
And in January 1986, the index was indexed
to a level of 100.
And you can see at the bottom of the
screen, the overall Small Business
Optimism Index is down for the month.
And it's at 95.7.
So, that's the composite number.
And then you can see the 10 components
being reported in the survey.
So, we see the plans to increase
employment, down 16%.
Plans to make capital outlays, down 22%.
Plans to increase inventories, down 3%.
Expecting the economy to improve, down
16%.
Expecting real sales to go higher, down
4%.
Current inventory, current inventory, the
only one that's going up.
Current job openings, down 32%.
Expected credit conditions, down 5%.
Is now a good time to expand, down 8%.
And earnings trends, minus 14%.
So, you can see the display that you would
get each month firstly.
But also, you know, this particular
report, you can see that it's pretty much
all down except the current levels of
inventory.
So, this is what you'll see each month
when you go to do your data collection.
And you just have to collect the data and
update your spreadsheets.
The actual sub-indices, so the 10
components, each individual one, the
survey is designed differently.
That's out of the scope of this video and
out of the scope of the PTM video series
to cover each individual survey design for
each of the components.
Obviously, if you wanted to do further
work on that, you can do.
Be our guest and go and figure out how
each of those surveys is designed.
But you can actually go on the website
here and you can get the actual SBET
questionnaire.
And you can download it and do further
work on that as well.
Now, if you want to go and collect all
data yourself or update spreadsheets on a
monthly basis, you just need to go to the
NFIB website.
And you can see on the left-hand side
here, there's a list of filters.
And the one you need is the one for
indicators.
And you need to select the monthly
frequency and seasonally adjusted numbers.
So, make sure that box is ticked for
seasonal adjustment.
And then in the center of the screen, on
the right-hand side of the filters, you
can see that there's a drop-down for
selecting indicators.
And the one we've got on the screen here
is the composite number, small business
optimism.
And in that drop-down, you can also get
the indicators for the sub-components as
well.
So, when you're doing this to get all
historical data, if you want to go through
the whole exercise yourself, this is where
you get the data.
And you just click on download data and it
drops into Excel and you get a download.
Or if you're doing it on a monthly basis
just to update your data, this is where
you would go to get it.
Now, just as a fail-safe for monthly data
collection, for your own monthly
processes, the historical data is
available on the NFIB website.
So, in the indicators section, and it is
available in Excel format, but it is
sometimes delayed.
So, there are alternative ways of getting
the data.
So, you can see the data at the time of
recording, investing.com in their economic
calendar for NFIB, small business
optimism.
The entire historical data set is there
and it's up to date, but that's at the
time of recording.
The only way to get all of the data from
investing.com is actually manually doing
it.
There's no automatic download into Excel.
So, you have to do that by copying and
pasting the data.
But do bear in mind that this data at
investing.com is only for the composite
index.
It doesn't include the components, the 10
components that we've looked at.
But this brings up another point, guys, as
well.
You know, at the time of recording,
throughout the PTM video series, we are
pointing you to sources that, at the time
of recording, have data sets and
information that are useful for leading
indicators and other areas of the process
that we're going to be looking at later in
the PTM video series.
And, of course, over time, sources can
change.
So, the best thing you can do is go
hunting for them by yourself.
You need to be self-reliant.
You need to practice looking for data and
information using keywords in Google and
going hunting for information yourself.
So, if in the future, for example, with
the NFIB data, it's not available at
investing.com, well, you just use some
keywords and you type into Google and you
go searching for the data elsewhere if you
want to get a more timely data release.
So, we're back here to one of the most
important ITPM principles of
self-sustainability.
You have to be able to do this all
yourself, forever.
You know, if you're going to be a
professional standard trader, you can't be
running around the internet asking people
what sources they got their information
from.
You have to be able to go and do that
yourself.
Okay.
That means you're totally
self-sustainable.
But anyway, let's continue with the NFIB
and let's have a look at the breakdown of
both leading and coincident components
that make up the composite index for the
small business index.
Well, if you were thinking earlier when I
asked you to think about what were the
leading and coincident components that
language like plans and expectations were
the keywords to leading components, then
you'd be right.
So, the leading components, plans to
increase employment, expansion plans,
plans to increase inventories, expecting
the economy to improve, expecting real
sales to go higher.
Now, we, as a company at ITPM, isolate
those five as leading components because
we believe they are the most useful in
terms of, from a trading and portfolio
management perspective, in terms of
creating your own leading index.
So, yes, you can take the data and create
your own leading index.
If you look at the coincident components,
you'll see that there is a small overlap
in terms of definition for leading and
coincident.
So, you can see, for example, we have
current inventory, we have current job
openings and earnings trends, which are
definitely coincident indicators.
But we also have arguably some leading
indicators there, expected credit
conditions, and plans to make capital
outlays.
We, as a company, isolate five of them.
So, plans to increase employment,
expansion plans, plans to increase
inventories, the expectation of economic
improvement, and expectation of real sales
to go higher.
So, we isolate those five, and we create
our own leading index with 20% weightings.
You can, if you want, very obviously, take
expected credit conditions and plans to
make capital outlays, and you can play
around with the data and create your own
leading components.
You know, if you put six or seven into
your bespoke leading indicator index,
that's fine, you can do that.
But we believe it's more useful to narrow
it down slightly to have five with a 20%
weighting or contribution of each
component to the overall bespoke leading
index that we create ourselves.
And why?
Well, if you think about, for example,
when you look at our leading components,
and you look at number two, expansion
plans.
Well, if you think about number eight and
nine, expected credit conditions and plans
to make capital outlays, there's an
overlap there.
Because if a business has expansion plans,
yes, they will take on more credit if
they're bullish about credit conditions,
and they will make more capital outlays.
So we just isolate expansion plans and
isolate, in total, five leading
components.
Now, if you go to the downloads area,
where we have the three spreadsheets,
you'll see the small business composite
index chart inside the files there.
And you can see visually what the entire
time series has done.
And on this chart, we've got the blue
line, which is the small business optimism
index going right back to 1986.
And we also have a white line, which is
the four month moving average of that
data.
And we highlight on the screen, the 100
level, which is the original index level.
And we can compare this to GDP growth.
And look at the number, look at the time
series relative to GDP growth, and look at
business cycle history, and put into
context what was going on at the time.
So for example, if you look at the early
to mid 2000s, that was obviously a very,
very bullish high point for a small
business in the United States.
And then we started to go below the 100
level in 2006-07.
And then below the 100 level, we continued
to keep going lower.
And then we got negative GDP growth.
And we also had a slowdown as well, going
into that condition.
Coming out of the global financial crisis,
2010, 11, 12, 13, you can see the index
level is still in the low 90s for small
business.
And small business was still really
struggling.
And it doesn't really get up to the 100
level until around 2015 briefly.
And then it goes lower again, again to the
low 90s.
So we're getting lower levels of GDP
growth associated with those numbers.
And small business optimism is below the
100 level.
And then we see in 2016, something happen
at the end of 2016, where small business
optimism just takes off.
Well, we'll be covering that a bit later
in the video.
But it's pretty obvious when you look at
the screen and you look at business cycle
history that levels or periods of strong
positive GDP growth are associated with
the NFIB Small Business Optimism Index
being above the 100 level.
Whenever it goes below the 100 level, it's
a warning sign for a slowdown in GDP
growth.
And definitely when it's in the low 90s,
we're going to get very, very slow GDP
growth or even contraction.
When we look at the data and compare it to
the S&P 500 year on year percentage
change, and we just visually look above
and below the 100 level.
If we look above the 100 level, through
our history, when we have the small
business optimism index above 100, we
should be expecting pretty strong or very
strong S&P 500 year on year percentage
returns.
And of course, there's no rulebook here,
guys, where we say, OK, if the index is at
102.5, what should we expect?
But we can see visually that we should be
expecting around 20% or above.
But again, this can change in the future.
It's not a rulebook, OK?
So if you look at above the 100 level,
generally speaking, we're looking at 15%
or above when the index is printing
consistently above the 100 level.
And if we look below the 100 level and we
look to around the 95 level, between 95
and 100, we're looking at decent returns
in the S&P 500 on a year on year basis.
We should be expecting anything between
flat and 15%.
And then as we get to 95 or below, what
should we be expecting?
Well, through our history, we should be
expecting flat GDP growth or even
contraction in GDP growth.
And we get associated with that negative
S&P 500 year on year percentage returns.
Now, don't forget, we are looking at the
aggregate index here, which is made up of
both leading and coincident components.
And this is why economists tend to view
the aggregate composite small business
optimism index as defined as a coincident
indicator.
But it does have leading components.
So arguably, because of these leading
components, there is a lead into GDP
growth and a lead into S&P 500 direction
and returns.
But of course, as traders and portfolio
managers, we've got money on the line and
we want to do a bit more digging and do a
bit more further work.
And we can actually strip out, as I
mentioned earlier, we can strip out the
main leading components.
And there's five of them and we can create
our own leading index.
So as mentioned earlier, we take out the
plans to increase employment, expansion
plans, plans to increase inventories,
expectation for the economy to improve,
and expected real sales to go higher.
And each of these receives an equal 20%
weighting in our bespoke leading index for
the leading components of the small
business optimism index.
So we've created our own index.
It's going to be useful for you to go into
the downloads area and have a look at that
and have a look at the formulas in the
Excel sheet as well.
And you can also learn how the index works
and you can play around with it if you
want.
You can take out expansion plans.
You can replace it with capital outlays.
You can play around with it and just
figure out how it works and the mechanics
of the data in the spreadsheet.
And the way it's been formatted in the
sheet is in the same way as the composite
coincident index that we just looked at,
where we have the SBO leading index in
blue.
In white, we have the four-month moving
average of that data.
And we've compared it to both GDP growth
and also S&P 500 direction and returns.
So the five areas that we've taken for
this leading index are bespoke index,
plans to increase employment,
now is a good time to expand or not, plans
to increase inventories, your expectation
of the economy to improve,
and your expectation of real sales to
improve.
Now, as mentioned previously, each of
these component surveys, their design is
all slightly different.
And you can see on the scale on the
left-hand side of these charts that the
measurements are different for each of the
10 components.
And yeah, these surveys are designed
individually, but the overall contribution
to the overall index for the NFIB Small
Business Index,
the composite index, each of these is 10%.
And for our leading index, it's 20%.
And you can go into the spreadsheet, look
at the formulas of how everything is
worked out for the leading bespoke index.
It's all very straightforward.
We're essentially adding up the five
isolated components.
So the five leading indicators, and we're
adding them up and just working out a
simple average.
So an average, a mean number for those
five leading components.
And that number is the ITPM SBO leading
index.
Now, we mentioned earlier that you can
look at the NFIB SBO data on a regional
basis.
In the downloads area, you'll also get
regional data for US small business
optimism.
It's really important to keep an eye on
this data, especially when you're looking
at the largest contributor regions overall
to US GDP.
And you can see here from the 2019 GDP
data, which is split up by billions of
dollars by state.
California, Texas and New York, and
arguably Florida as well.
But California, Texas and New York, by far
the biggest contributors on a state basis
to US GDP.
The NFIB splits everything up into
regions.
You'll find California in the Pacific
region as defined by the NFIB.
You'll find Texas in the West South
Central region as defined by the NFIB.
And you'll find New York State in the
Northeast region as defined by the NFB.
Additionally, in the downloads area,
you're also going to find industry data
for US small business optimism.
And this industry data and the trends that
come from it can be useful when you're
using it in conjunction with the ISM
manufacturing reports on business industry
data.
And the ISM services industry data when
you're looking for particular industry
trends in order to locate single stock
trade ideas.
Now, if you recall, with the ISM
manufacturing and ISM services, there were
industry stats that were published every
month by the ISM for the sectors.
And both ISM manufacturing and ISM
services also showed, for each industry
sector, they showed the trend in months
and they were calculated for you.
The problem with the SPO data is that that
job is not done for you.
They don't calculate the industry trend in
terms of months.
You have to do that yourself manually.
So, if you recall, the ISM manufacturing
and non-manufacturing sectors, you see
them on the screen there.
You can see we have the number of months
in growth or contraction.
The SPO data doesn't provide that.
You would have to do that manually
yourself.
Now, when using all of this together, when
you're doing a quantitative assessment,
doing your monthly updates on an industry
level, you can use, obviously, the SPO
industry data together with the ISM
manufacturing and ISM non-manufacturing.
So, services data, use it together and
look for clues and trends and turning
points in particular sectors.
Now, let's revert to our useful exercise
of having a look at this particular
leading indicator, the NFIB Small Business
Optimism Index.
So, that's the coincident indicator as
defined by economists, but we know there's
leading components to it.
So, arguably, there is a leading element
to it.
Let's have a look at it in recent business
cycle history.
What we've got on the screen here is the
period from January 16 to January 19.
And this period, if we look, in
particular, from May 16 to August 18,
within that three-year period, you can see
on the right-hand side, I've denoted some
pretty important historical moments that
were important.
Important for small business.
And it was basically at the beginning, if
you look at May 16, when Trump received
the Republican nomination for president.
And if we fast-forward to November 16,
that was when Trump had his election win,
and you can see small business optimism
starting to increase.
In May, it was 93.8.
And when Trump won the presidency, it was
98.4.
And then in January 17, when we had the
Trump inauguration, between November 16
and Jan 17, there was that big jump that
we looked at earlier on the chart of the
Small Business Optimism Index from 98.4 to
105.9.
Fast-forward again to November 17, small
business optimism sitting at a very high
level of 107.1, and that's when the
corporate tax cuts that Trump was running
on actually went into effect.
So the corporate tax cuts of 35% to 21%.
So you can see that the Small Business
Optimism Index, after the Trump win,
rallied hard, and then rallied all the way
up, up until the corporate tax cut, and
actually peaked in August 2018.
And if you remember, what do we recall
about August 2018?
Yes, that was when the ISM peaked as well,
the ISM Manufacturing Index.
Now, of course, we're not going to get
into political debates here in the PTM
video series.
We are all about trading and portfolio
management, and what these leading
indicators mean for the economy, and what
it means for our portfolios and our
pocket.
Very obviously, a corporate tax cut from
35% to 21% alleviates a massive headwind
for small business.
And the Trump presidency was very, very
good for small business.
If we look on the chart here, I've
highlighted areas in the past when the
Small Business Optimism Index was above
100.
And I've also highlighted the period where
Trump received the nomination, the
Republican nomination for president, which
was May 2016.
You can see during pretty much all of the
Obama years, the Small Business Optimism
Index was below 100.
And Trump receiving the nomination, the
Republican nomination for president,
occurs in May 2016.
And then in November 2016, it takes off
after the election win on the expectation
of better small business conditions from
small business owners,
because they were expecting the corporate
tax rate to be cut.
Then we get to the peak there in August
2018 of around 108 on the Small Business
Optimism Index.
And if you recall from previous videos, we
covered that period, August 18 to August
2019.
This was when the yield curve was
flattening and eventually briefly
inverting until the Fed lowered rates in
July, September, October 19.
And we previously showed you the UMCSI
during that period, never actually entered
into a consumer recession or went into
consumer recession territory during that
period.
And actually, the Small Business Optimism
Index never went below 100 during that
period either.
So the period, August 2018 to August 2019,
and that was due, obviously, to overall
low record interest rates.
But of course, it's because of the low
interest rates and also because the
corporate tax rate was lowered.
So if we think about all of our leading
indicators and filling in the colour for
this picture over this time period,
the period of economic stress during the
period August 18 to August 19 was more of
a global manufacturing, big business trade
slowdown,
not because of the US small business
sector and the US consumer.
And again, this is a clear example of why
you need to be a student of business cycle
history and understand what was going on
with each of the leading indicators and
each part of the US economy at certain
moments in time.
So it's important to follow all the
numbers and interpret them properly so you
can really understand the picture in the
US and global economy in the future when
you're doing your monthly processes and
trying to understand the macroeconomic
picture of the world and what you expect
in the future.
So let's summarise here for the NFIB Small
Business Optimism Index.
We can go and get the data. It's publicly
available. It's free information.
You just have to be diligent enough to do
the work on a monthly basis.
It's very important to our outlook for US
GDP growth and S&P 500 direction and
returns.
We have to use the subcomponents in
conjunction with money markets indicators
and other leading indicators to get a
broad picture and understanding of the US
economy
And what's driving US GDP growth and S&P
500 direction and returns.
Our bespoke index, so the ITPM NFIB
leading SBO index of our five times 20%
contributor weighted indicators gives us a
very good idea of expected GDP and S&P 500
direction.
What the index measures, so small business
owner sentiment for the future prospects
of the US economy is also very, very
important.
Why? Because it's very closely tied to
consumer sentiment. Why? Because 50% of
the US workforce work for small
businesses.
So remember when we looked at the UM CSI
and we were gauging consumer sentiment and
future consumer spending, well, guess
what?
Because 50% of the US workforce work for
small businesses.
Their own sentiment and outlook for the
future prospects of the US economy, the
small business owners, is very closely
tied to their own expected future
consumption.
So tied to consumer sentiment. So we
obviously use this in conjunction with all
of our leading indicators, but it is
especially tied to consumer sentiment.
So from a professional traders and
portfolio managers perspective, the small
business sentiment index is very
important.
Engaging for us which way the wind is
blowing for GDP growth, S&P 500 direction
and magnitude of stock market returns and
therefore our directional portfolio
buyers.
We use the SVO leading indicator
components as a guide and in conjunction
with our money market indicators and other
leading indicators to predict turning
points in the business cycle and trends
and therefore our portfolio buyers, long,
short or neutral.
And we use it on an industry level as well
in conjunction with the ISM manufacturing
and ISM non-manufacturing industry data
for clues and light bulb indications for
single stock trade ideas in particular
industries.
And never forget the Fed is also watching
the monthly small business optimism
leading data also tells us what we should
expect from the Fed in terms of likely
future policy response.
And if you are interested in US politics
and potentially trying to predict future
election results, small business sentiment
is also very important politically in the
US because it literally means employment
prospects for the future of average
working and middle class families in the
US.
So it can signify both voting intention
and the outcomes of future elections.
So that just about wraps it up guys for
analyzing small business sentiment in the
United States.
The NFIB SVO index is very important.
It's important that on a monthly basis,
you do go and get this data and get a
general gauge and understanding of what's
going on with a small business in the US
and put it into context with what's going
on at the time and all the other leading
indicators.
Up next, we're going to be having a look
at cyclical commodity prices.
And we're going to go straight into the
next video.
So I'll see you there.